in this wedge what would you like to
hear a rap about okay asparagus is a
food and that's okay hey it's late we're
not all paying attention luckily before
this person said asparagus a quiet voice
at the back said popemobile which with
who was that he said that what was he
I'm sorry it's a well sorry [ __ ] your
suggestion mate you've got ratted out
over there someone like look if we're
gonna do it we're gonna do it properly
Chris hope the meals a good suggestion
but it's not from that section yes
Abbey Road feels like a very British
based heckle just like these from there
I'll say it okay Abbey Road that's a
very very valid suggestion I like that
suggestion Abbey Road thank you very
much sorry asparagus and thank you very
much for keeping our community safe over
there really we can't have this and hey
I like popemobile as a suggestion but
you know to be fair you did transgress
so Abbey Road from over there I'm gonna
come to you guys not you guys you guys
over here what yeah you put your putting
did you have a suggestion houndstooth
clothing my gosh you you were shouting
at meringue Zia weren't you and I was
like she's very drunk ah she's probably
gonna suggest something and you know
what I was not expecting houndstooth
clothing that was great that's a great
suggestion houndstooth clothing if
you're not familiar it's that clothing
which has the houndstooth band which I'm
very familiar with so houndstooth
clothing Abbey Road will come to the
back of the room back of the room what's
your like a rap about well you're not on
the back of the room are you so what was
wait wait
okay the popemobile is creeping back in
feels like it's my time to shine because
there's a lot of shouting at the same
time it's hard to pick one so let's try
a one-hour time what were they mala
isn't that a very offensive term I mean
I don't know who Sam is and I don't
really care
people like suggesting birthdays like oh
it's my special moment but then for that
bit of the rap everyone else in here is
like I hate Sam I hate Sam so much okay
an aggressive man saying yeah baby it's
a pretty good suggestion and I I hope
that that was Sam who said that okay so
houndstooth clothing Abbey Road a
terrifying yeah baby because it's not
like the Austin Powers boys they did in
it was like please don't come after me
at home okay
middle of the room you guys heads
includes the front I'm gonna divide you
up into left and right left hand side
what's the rug going to be about
rainbows and leprechauns is again very
stereotypical towards the Irish people
and I don't like that what you saying
cognitive dissonance that is holding two
conflicting ideas in your head at the
same time is that right yeah okay cool
no one likes that suggestion either but
it's a valid okay cool guys over here
so far the suggestions have been a
variable quality I'm hoping that you
guys can really nail it with this what's
it gonna be I feel I fit again so that
came from this side but you did say
shmegmer
which
was also it is not pronounced with an SH
usually but it came at the same time as
someone who said Sherlock Holmes and so
I feel like you kind of teamed up like
like Sherlock a watson and were like if
we say sherlock holmes in shmegmer he's
gonna say the suggestions sherlock
holmes ish magma and yes I am Jesus I
apologize for these suggestions but on
your own heads be it this lovely people
of a comedy and magic club that's gonna
be a freestyle rap as I said a rap made
up on the spot based in telling those
suggestions the suggestions once more
for your delectation and reminder our
cognitive dissonance houndstooth
clothing Abbey Road Sherlock Holmes
shmegmer and a scary man saying yeah
baby don't worry it won't be anywhere
near as atrocious the embarrassingly bad
as you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white boy to be let's drop
that beat good sir let's have some fun
don't say chug it mate sir it's alcohol
free as well thank you trying to get me
been drinking man shouting now chug it
knocking back hit the tip of the glass
up so high now and moral wise in the
soul good guy but I arrived at my
destination how do you feel I was
carried here not within the popemobile
because you got snitched out yes on you
got told I walked it on a zebra crossing
Abbey Road see four guys there Heights
are not equal George Ringo John Paul of
the Beatles stand-in there on the
pedestrian crossing if you're in London
you will be tossing all the visas at the
people who take the photos cuz the
tourists hold up the traffic slow down
it goes outside the Abbey Road Studios
they actually renovate if the bigger
your you can visit there maybe cut a
brand new track that let me put a little
thought in my head to the back cognitive
dissonance I'll say yeah again it's like
a combat in your brain is hard to intend
and engage those things good since I was
born
I had an admiration for the leprechauns
and this not dissing than to put with
the rainbow but if you are Irish it's
painful and shameful to look at those
guys
the island and say they're all small
green men with gold in there and there
I'm moving and I'm saying it I'm like
Sherlock Holmes I'm just playing it a
houndstooth pattern on my cat
deerstalker walking down Baker Street if
you know I oughta look at haberdasher in
the window I see a nice bit of fabric I
say bro
Watson come in know what's on display I
take a bit of houndstooth then I walk
away but now Sherlock is the criminal he
wears houndstooth much better than or
legal is better than pinstripes or any
other fabric if I see a satin
houndstooth the habit I store right up
there in my attic if I saw a man in the
dark I never attack it unless he came up
to me a lady in the situation said yeah
[Applause]
I'm reaching in my handbag pulling out
mace spray in there why are you saying
it to me I'm on infant he tries to hide
but I get him right in front of his eyes
yeah this is a quiz you should only say
that in maternity ward when you're
positive yeah baby get their lane kasi
an infant is born now and it's still
late to its mother by an umbilical cord
if you see Sherlock in the bedroom be
assured that he keeps his foreskin
mighty clean he's got a toothbrush that
he's proud and breathing in front of the
mirror he's really really clever high IQ
Sherlock Holmes playing no Smeg but he
pulls the foreskin retracts it back has
a little scrub has a little scratch and
none in there we all agree it's more
preferable when there's no big cheese I
don't want that long problem is des
magmar when you piss if it smells bad
kicking up a lot of us is it Smeg Morsy
because you recently a asparagus thank
you very much for watching please watch
more with playlists spirit subscribe
here like
comment all those things shouting bye